Is the Internet a good thing we should embrace,...
...or something we should be wary of?
The way I see it, the Internet is most definitely both.
The Internet enables any computer in the world to communicate with any other computer in the world.
Individuals, companies, and governments are all connected with each other.
With the Internet, it all boils down to the free flow of information.
In other words, individuals from any nation can freely communicate with individuals from any other nation...
...as if there were no national borders.
While this ease of communication and access to information is normally positive in nature,...
...it can be used by people with evil motives to spread falsehoods.
It can be used by criminals to exploit people to gain access to sensitive or personal information...
...such as identity numbers or credit card numbers.
Like anything created by man,...
...the Internet is harmless in nature, and can be used for either good or bad.
So, I think that, as we embrace the Internet,...
...we should do so carefully.